- You know, this is our
a little pasta baby.
We're breathing life into this thing.
Keep watching, you'll see what happens.
Suspenseful.
What's up everyone?
I'm chef Joe Sasto,
and today I am playing a
game called make it pasta
where we have this mystery wheel here.
I'm going to spin it and then turn
whatever that is into pasta.
Let's give it a whirl, huh?
Apple pie.
Apple pie's iconic.
I'm okay with that one.
I'm into it. I feel it.
Let's get some apple pie and
give it a little taste test.
So we have our pie here.
Classic.
We all know what's in an apple pie.
We got our apples, cinnamon,
sugar, butter, pie crust.
I mean, I could cut myself a slice or
I could just go right into the center.
It's my pie, I make my own decisions.
Hm. Nice sweetness on the
apples, not too sugary.
Soft, still got a little bit of crunch.
I could do something with that.
Gears are turning, I know
what we're going to do.
Let's make it pasta.
First things first here, we
got to make a pasta dough.
I have an idea for this.
I've made plenty of pasta doughs,
but I haven't done one quite
like this using pie crust,
but I have an idea.
I think it's going to work.
I'm gonna start by kind of dissecting
part of my pie here,
pulling just this lattice
crust from the top.
And I'm gonna put that
into a food processor.
I don't want any apples.
So pie crust pasta dough, super authentic.
You could probably find
this nowhere in Italy.
So we got flour, double O, our pie crust.
We'll go here, I'm going
to use all this flour
cause we're kind of staying
in that apple pie world,
they got a little bit of cinnamon.
So our dough is going to
have like a hint of cinnamon,
just a little kiss.
I have some dry milk powder here.
Kind of like carrying
those flavors, I feel like,
with a dessert pasta, some
milk powder would be nice.
Get that flavor of milk in there.
Put a little bit of salt.
You always want some salt in pasta dough.
Then we're going to throw the lid on and
get all that pie crust broken
up before we add our eggs.
All right, I feel good about that.
It actually, it already
smells really nice.
Crust is like blooming in there.
We got our flour base and then
just like all pasta doughs,
we're gonna work in a little bit of egg.
So I'm going to go mostly yolks and
then some whole eggs to bring it together.
Starting with just the yolks.
One at a time.
And I wish I could say
I had a recipe for this,
but honestly, I'm just,
we're making it up as we go.
This is a stage. There are no swaps.
This is happening. This is a real life.
So now we go whole egg.
Let's go another whole egg.
You can see the dough's coming together.
Let's stop and check the hydration here.
Oh, look at that.
I think we might be on
our way to pasta dough.
All right, let's get all
this stuff out of the way
and we'll start kneading.
Everyone's favorite part of pasta making,
we gotta knead this, we
gotta develop some gluten.
So I'm going to go right
here onto our countertop.
So let's bring this all together and
then just like all pasta doughs,
we're just going to
work this, kneading it.
It doesn't feel too far
off from a pasta dough.
You know, the color is a
little like untraditional
in that sense, normally you
got that like bright yellow,
and as we keep kneading,
this should smooth out and
become nice and supple.
Supple and smooth.
This is where I'd normally want to
throw it in a stand mixer.
Let the machine do all the work,
but I'm doing this for you guys,
we're going to do this all by hand.
Fatto a mano.
It's our little pasta baby.
We're breathing life into this thing.
Keep watching, you'll see what happens.
So we're getting a little
smoother all the way around there.
We got our apple pie pasta
dough, I'm going to wrap this up.
We're going to set this aside to rest
and now it's time to get
started on the filling.
Let's do it.
Now this I'm very excited for
cause I feel like it can be
used for more than just a
pasta filling.
We got our luscious,
yummy apple pie filling.
We'll go all the apples
down into the food processor
to kind of like bulk this up,
make sure I have enough for all my pasta,
add a nice kind of creamy richness to it,
I'm going go one of my
favorite pasta filling bases,
we'll go a little bit of ricotta,
some mascarpone cheese.
So essentially we're making a
apple ricotta cannoli filling.
A little bit of salt.
I'm going to use some vanilla bean paste.
You could use vanilla bean extract,
you could use vanilla beans.
Now we got powdered sugar,
just to sweeten things up in there.
I know there's already
sugar on the apples,
but we got those two new cheeses in here
that can be a little bland.
I don't want it to be savory,
we're going sweet pasta dolce.
Dessert pasta.
And yes, for all of
you Italians out there,
sweet pasta is a thing.
Trust me on that one.
Look at that.
I mean that's pasta filling.
Let's give it a quick little taste.
I'm just going to go drink this.
No, actually we're going to
put it into a piping bag and
then I want, we'll make one
more component for our pasta.
I'm gonna use the rest of that crust
to make a crumble rumble topping.
Let's make some streusel.
So, if you know me,
you know I'm a big fan
of some crumble rumble.
I like texture.
Now in the world of apple pie,
I feel like there are those
two schools of thought.
You have that streusely topping,
which some people might
call a cobbler or crumble,
an apple crumble or crisp.
Sometimes you find that lattice crust,
where it's all pie dough.
So I'm going to try to fuse
and mold the two together
by using my pie crust that's leftover
to make a streusel like topping
to go on top of our dessert pasta.
Sound good, yeah?
I feel really good about this.
I don't know. How do you feel?
So we got the rest of our
crust down into a bowl
we just go a little bit
of all-purpose flour,
maybe a lot a bit of all purpose flour.
Making it up. There are
no recipes for this.
We got some brown sugar.
You got some white sugar.
Little pinch of salt.
I have melted butter.
This is going to make things even better
cause butter is better and more delicious.
Oh yeah.
If you want to double down on the butter,
I'm not gonna judge you.
I support that decision.
One of my favorite spices,
a little bit of nutmeg.
Warm some things up here.
We just want to give this a nice mix.
Crumble up all that pie crust.
I almost want to eat this by the handful,
but self-control all right?
I'm gonna throw this onto a baking sheet.
I don't mind some big chunks in there.
You could always break it up a little bit.
Spread that out so it bakes evenly.
I'm going to pop this into the
oven while this is baking and
the dough is resting.
I have one more thing to
make this a little extra.
We're gonna make a caramel sauce
to drizzle on top of our pasta.
We just got some white sugar.
We're going down into the
bottom of a pot or pan.
And we're going to let that sugar melt,
the water is going to cook off,
the sugar is going to start to caramelize.
We're going to hit it with a
little cream, a little butter,
make it nice and luscious.
Then we'll have the perfect
topping for our pasta.
Sugar is caramelized.
We got that dark amber.
Things are gonna get wild real quick
as soon as we add this cream.
So cream is in there,
our pan is cooled down.
Caramel is on its way.
We'll add a little bit of butter.
I'm going to season this
up with a little salt,
a little bit of salt in sweet things
make them taste sweeter.
A little bit of sugar in savory things,
make them taste more savory.
And then we're just using
that carry over heat,
melt in our butter.
Look at that. Salted caramel.
Who doesn't love apples and caramel?
So this we're just going
to put here in our bowl and
save until we're ready.
It's like a caramel hot tub in there.
Time to make some pasta,
bring this all together.
Our dough has been resting.
We can remove it here from our wrap.
Look at that.
Pasta dough and we're done. That's it.
You can all go home.
No, just kidding, we'll turn
it into pasta shapes now.
We'll get a little bit of flour down.
This is my favorite part.
I always like to start it
off just with a rolling pin
to get us going.
I'm going to go split it in half.
So I'm gonna keep this in here
just so it doesn't dry out.
(machine whirring)
There we go.
Our apple pie cinnamon crust pasta dough.
A combination of words
I didn't think I would ever say out loud
and yet here we are.
Now, all we gotta do is get
this cut up into pieces and
make some caramelle.
And you know what?
Before anyone asks, all his
trim, we're going to eat it.
We're making chef snacks.
We're not wasting anything.
Everybody calm down.
I'm a professional, all right?
So we have our apple pie filling.
Give this a little spray
and that's going to help
us to seal our dough.
For everybody following along,
your folding over the rectangle,
I want to seal down
that first notch or flap
combining the two layers into
one, folding that over itself,
and then we're going to
seal the sides again.
Now combining the four
layers down into two.
So our thickness is, cook well,
and then we're just pinching
up and squeezing the sides
to flare out the ends
like a candy wrapper.
Like everything, you know,
the more you practice, the better you get.
The moment I've been waiting for,
hopefully we've all been waiting for,
we're going to cook these, plate these
and give them an official taste test.
Just like the start of
every really great thing,
we're going to make
some brown butter here.
Let's get a nice little
couple of tablespoons
down in the bottom of the pan.
And you know what?
If you're at home and you
want to make this ala mode,
I support that decision.
So we've got our butter heating up,
the water's going to evaporate,
those milk solids are going to separate,
they're going to float
to the bottom of the pan,
all that's going to start
to toast and caramelize
and right before our eyes
we'll have brown butter.
We're getting all this beautiful,
wonderful, nutty flavor.
We'll keep it on the lighter
side of brown butter.
Set this aside, boil some
water and cook some pasta.
Boiling water, little
bit of salt in this case,
I don't need it like totally seasoned
as if I was cooking a savory pasta,
but a little bit of salt goes a long way.
We will drop our noods down there.
Go noods, go.
Now fresh pasta only is going
to take a couple of minutes.
As soon as we see these float,
we should be able to go
right into our brown butter,
caramelle in the butter and
a little bit of that starchy pasta water
emulsify together with the brown butter.
As soon as we see this coming
to a nice little sizzle,
everybody's married and
happy and romantic together
in the pan, we have ourselves
a plate of apple pie pasta.
I almost forgot what we
were making for a second.
We got ourselves some
pasta dolce my friends.
Here we go, caramelles.
I'm going to plate this real nice.
We'll go right down the
center of the plate.
A little bit of that brown butter sauce.
Be sure to find the
biggest spoon that you can.
I want caramel next.
We got that salted
caramel, little drizzle,
we don't want it to be too sweet.
We have our streusel crumble rumble here,
look how that turned out,
and just a few crumbled
up kind of over the top.
It smells like apple pie.
Like apple pie just came out of the oven
except it just came out of the pasta pot.
And then because what
is any fancy dessert,
nothing, without a little bit of mint.
I'm going to pick off some
of these little baby leaves.
Just add a little bit of color,
a little greenery for the scenery.
All right, check this out.
We have our apple pie
caramelle our salted caramel
apple pie streusel,
Alex, we need to get her
in here to taste this.
Surprise. Welcome.
- I like a surprise. Ooh!
- So we have, I'm not even
gonna tell you what it is.
- Wow, they're like little candies.
- They are little candies.
They're called caramelle
it's the shape of the pasta.
- Caramelle.
- We landed on an ingredient,
I'm not going to tell you what
the ingredient or thing was.
- Okay. I'm so excited.
- So you get to try it and then guess.
- You know, I've been
dying to try your pasta.
- I'm glad to hear that.
- I think I now like the
official taste tester of Tasty.
I love it! It's less work for me.
- What does it smell like?
Tell us, any guesses
based on smell and look.
- Wonderful smells. Oh, butter.
- Butter?
- It smells like butter.
- Yes, there's butter. We had butter
- My favorite food.
Oh my God. It's fantastic.
The thing is, I know that
it's a dessert pasta,
but you nailed the balance
between the salty sweet.
- Not too much, right?
- It's not much. No.
It's apple pie.
- Nailed it.
- Apple pie.
- Yes. Good.
High five? Yes.
- High five.
- Thank you, Alex.
- You deserve all the credit for this one.
- Appreciate it.
And you guys thank you for watching.
Let me know down in the comments
what I should make into pasta next.
- This was a curve ball. I
wouldn't be able to do this.
Good luck!
- I would love to watch
you try to do this.
(laughing)
- I know! I'll help you, I'll help you.
- That'll be the next
video. That's the next one.
Oh yes!
(upbeat music)